in the previous episode can I help you
sir well I hope so my name is Scott
Shelby I'm a private detective when my
boy Razer disappeared yes I received a
letter with a locker ticket
inside inside the locker I found this
box
help Dad where are you I'm so cold
[Music]
open come on that's just going to hurt
tomorrow oh
[__]
beautiful is she
alive how's going bro my name
is welcome back to some crying babies in
the living room but hey it's okay
because we saved save that little cute
little
cute little thing hi baby how you
doing uh oh yeah B bandages need some
bandages and
disinfected bandages
somewhere got to be here somewhere where
you should have some bandages in the
bathroom all right let me get over there
start moving start you can do this work
with me there we go jolly good all
right probably in this Locker no not in
the sink bad
Scot ah [__] it you got to wash your
hands every now and then don't you what
you don't wash your
hands that's disgusting let's see all
right I need this and this uh-huh and
this all right take what you need
bro and then I'm going to run away just
kidding all right let's save her don't
even worry about it bro I told gos not
it's all right I'm here for you Susan
don't worry about you'll be all right
I'll take care of
you I totally know how to do
this she likes
it yeah that's got to burn stay with me
stay with me Susan Susan do you hear me
Susan stay with me Susan
I'm stay with
me okay come
on
all
right he's really good at
[Music]
that there I'm really good at that
should stop the bleeding luckily the
wounds aren't too
deep hey you're you're lucky you can't
cut that deep you little pit
okay my
baby my baby needs me oh now she
cares
right you stay there I'll take take care
of the baby
okay do you know what to
do with a baby I mean you eat the diaper
and Li I'm a private eye there's nothing
I can't
do your name is
Emily gotcha well my name is I don't
give a
[__] all right I'm just kidding I care
all right all right Emmy L can I call
you Emmy Emmy poo
no what Su
B ew I better wash out first I wash my
hands before I swear to God I did it
before all right here we
[Music]
go Jesus Christ stop crying I'm coming
all
right God damn it babysitter emulator
2,000 all right let see we get so what
seems to be the problem huh oh going by
the smell I got a pretty good
idea disgusting don't tell me I have to
do
this no I
refuse God damn it all right how do we
do this
Emily I don't like this either okay you
like it apparently God damn it uh
hell this game has some weird ass
moments all right she likes it I'm happy
for you
Bri oh
[__] there you go fresh new baby fresh
baby fresh baby sex sex Dro me are you
happy is I
cat little
emu em poo hey a come on matter I
thought we solve the problem
yeah em o em snow what do you want M um
she's probably
hungry good thing I have to where are
you going Scott
Shelby there you
are there it is I thought I saw this
little thing
I guess I better warm this thing
up oh that's a
ni ni little
thing and then we
wait oh that was
quick all right you got to make sure
it's the right tempature
[Music]
though nope we're not going to do that
all
right come here Emy poo oh Emily are you
hungry H you hold on I'll just tilt this
ball a little bit so you don't choke
okay don't choke Emily don't you dare
choke Emily don't
choke
ah who's sat in the
background what the hell is this game
oh wow she drank all of it didn't
[Music]
you it's sleepy time for Emily
now oh we got to make her burp
even come on so many oh okay I got to
click come on Emily give me a good old
burp burp there we go good job
Emily you're feeling good now
right
now I'm going to walk you very g a nice
the
hell okay bro uh it really is a baby
ulator
D oh no I'm doing it
[Music]
fine a he play
I all right let's put it down gently no
I did it too fast
oops oh no W sorry
kid you're not done rocking I want more
cuddles okay Jesus Christ come here
Emily
[Music]
poo
all right gently put her
down
gently
gently don't let her wake up yeah
serious
business all
right I'm out of
here what was this all about I don't
even know who she is
is all right let's check on
her all right it's time to talk thanks
for looking after my
[Music]
baby hey anytime girl I didn't want to
leave
her I just couldn't cope
anymore
well you do what you got to do girl not
having Jeremy around Jeremy he was such
a good
boy can't understand why anyone would
want to hurt
him do you take care of this baby on
your own doesn't Jeremy's father live
with you
anymore he
disappeared the day after
Jeremy I don't know what happened to
him
maybe maybe he couldn't take
it he went on the TR ever since I've had
to look after Emily all on my own
and couldn't do it
anymore I
understand did your husband say anything
before he disappeared did he leave a
note or
something
no he left the house without a word
and there was just the cell phone
a cell phone give me the cell phone yeah
I found a cell phone in his
dresser I'm sure it wasn't his I'd never
seen it
before I tried to turn it on but it
didn't work H do you still have
it yeah it's um it's in a
drawer Liv room you can have it if you'd
like I'm sure it's more used to you than
to me
do you have any family or anybody to
help
you yeah my
mother I didn't want to ask her for
anything you need to ask her we don't do
it get
along but I guess I'm out of
options all right girl well look after
yourself and Emily yeah you better take
care of that
girl
I don't really trust her but hey we need
that
evidence
okay uh drawer in the living room shh
Can't Make Emily up isn't it the living
room oh here it
is all right that thing is
mine
I don't know what that was I just felt
like it was
necessary
okay let's go hopefully we'll play as
Ethan no we'll play as a girl
probably I don't know what do you think
I think the
girl Madison yeah that's her
[Music]
name so this affects the story I think
not sure but you can you can choose
whether you take care of the baby and
all that [__] or if you even save her
actually but I don't I don't really know
what it changes to be
honest all right [__] where is
Ethan Ethan [__] Hawk wait
that's not his name that is Mission
impost what oh I'm
sorry
the hell this
[Music]
happen all right time to take our first
trial to save our son this is pretty
much
the what I think is really interesting
about this game is uh how they make you
as a
player decide how far you want to go to
save the ones you love
uh so here's when you you make these
tough decisions not really here excuse
me excuse
me excuse me princess oh huh sorry
didn't see you well it's not uh what can
I do you for I'm Not underneath the car
so you know um I got
this I'd like to
get my
car
what
what hey you're a pretty patient guy you
are that car's been there for 2 years
wow we took it out for a drive every
month and checked the Tires and
Batteries just like you
said here it's the third floor down the
service elevator is at the far end of
the garage now you have yourself a good
one Chief all right Chief
Two
oh there's the elevator the third floor
is I
think I don't really know about me but I
know about you clamy cl clamy clamy
clamy cl I don't know about me but I
know
about this elevator seems
safe bad Ethan there we
go this game is so
cool I love
it there we
go they're actually making a new game
soon um I think it will be out 2013 I
hope at least it looks awesome can't
wait to play it all right what do we got
which one is
mine
he oh there it is
I hope it's a nice
one and it's
uh piece
of piece of I don't even know ah [__] it
let's go inside and see what's
up all
right
is there anything there
nope love
compartment what do we
got porn magazines condoms
no
uh nothing
huh oh there we go what is
[Music]
this
I guess I'm supposed to put the memory
card your destination is four miles from
here okay leave the parking lot and take
the first
right thank
you and let's go God damn it and let's
go
here we go
BR take a left at the next intersection
all
right keep to the right and take the
first
exit ah all right this is really
difficult and the ah
what's really interesting about this
these part is that if you fail it
drastically changes the story so I I I
don't want to fail I don't know it's
there's no right and wrong either I mean
if you fail that's all
right you have fre I I want I want to
clear it clear it are you ready to show
your courage in order to save your son
yes listen carefully let's do it [__]
the highway and drive against the
traffic before 5 miles no if you haven't
reached your destination in 5 minutes
you will have
failed oh my God I got to do it for Sean
I'd do anything to save my
son I have hope if I succeed I'll get
more letters for the hangman it's my
only need no turning back
now what there's been speakers on all
along and I didn't even know it is all
right here we
go I accept it do it for Sean sake I
have no
choice do it do
it
Oh wrong way I don't
care Oh left that was the right push
up oh
[__] he this is crazy I can do come on
left and it's right why do I keep saying
oh [__] I'm
sorry wa
oh oh waa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa come on BR miles to
go four miles are you kidding
me get out of the way wow that was
close lava how come on
lava
W don't kill people
W no what I can't see you still to go
before you oh no not the fake
one who no no no no oh [__] left why did
I keep saying alive you still have to
finally
W I can do this I can do
it come on move out the goddamn wayve
out I clicked
up oh the cops oh
[__] now I'm sure they don't give a [__]
oh never mind you still have one mile to
go before you reach your one M come
[Music]
onck hey how you doing nothing out of
the ordinary this driving in in the
opposite don't mind me really oh [__] oh
[__] wa holy
[__] woo [__]
left
damn hey don't shoot me
bro
whoa oh [__] did I make it or what
destination reached yes please press the
screened press the screen Ethan
destination reached press please press
the screen destination reached all right
we can't [__] up now please press your
reward is in the glove
compartment the key is inside the GPS
your can you talk obnoxious
compartment the key is inside the
GPS ah ah it's up
up come
on come
on do
what
take
it go out come on Ethan we can't die
now
ow right I said it right God damn it
h left then God God damn it
h whoa nice going
oh go Ethan go
Ethan you go
girl we did it friend that was freaking
epic all right on that note I will end
this episode but Lu very if you enjoyed
subscribe to become a bro today and I'll
see you next episode love you
[Music]
there
[Applause]
oh